transporter ses emplettes à montréal ne
se fera plus de la même façon dans deux
ans tous les petits gestes sont
importants et la ville va de l'avant
pour interdire les sacs d'épicerie
mais pas tous les sacs pour les fruits
ou les médicaments seront toujours
permis ainsi que les sacs plus épais de
plus de 50 microns mais les détaillants
craignent que l'alternative coûte plus
cher au consommateur que le 5 sous
facturés pour les sacs actuelle on va
devoir offrir d'autres types de singes
qui vont nécessairement des sacs avec
plus de plastique ou encore des sacs de
papier qui ont pas un meilleur bilan
environnemental en bout de ligne c'est
pas vraiment une belle mesures
environnementales convient de mettre de
l'avant montréal
on vient tout simplement de bannir une
alternative sur cette question les
consommateurs sont divisés il ya des
gens qui arrivent du bureau puis on peut
penser qu'ils l'ont paul sac
si on leur donne des sacs de papier soit
cette nuit il est un chose que montréal
fasse ce tournant le qui en fait un flic
très peu le selon moins pour les gens
d'apporter des sacs réutilisables
on va se débrouiller autrement le tout
pour sa part l'industrie du sac de
plastique s'inquiète de l'impact que
cela aura sur les milliers d'emplois
dans son secteur
ici les sacs sont faites ici
automatiquement et les sacs d'épicerie
et 50 microns c'est techniquement ça ne
se fait
il espère pouvoir rencontrer le maire
retrouve des me voir il me le pape est
toujours ouverte
mais enfin choix de société présentement
et on bannit paul l'ensemble des sacs de
plastique certains types de sacs de
plastique donc on peut à ce moment-là
s'ajuster et que l'on fasse preuve
d'innovation le bannissement des sacs de
plastique n'est qu'une première étape
pour la ville de montréal
le maire denis coderre veut aussi
éventuellement interdire les bouteilles
de plastique quand et comment cela reste
à voir
ici carrément radio canada bon rien